[Music]
oh when you think it can't get lower
fake news cnn's don lemon trying to
claim that
this summer's left-wing riots were
totally justified because they were
based on facts
okay then you got fake jake tapper
sinking to his new low attacking a gop
congressman double amputee veteran brian
mast
actually questioning this man's
patriotism
and his military service because he
wouldn't go along with the democrats
impeachment sham
wow take a look that's relevant what
you're saying right now is relevant
because congressman brian mast a
republican from florida
who lost his legs by the way fighting
for democracy abroad
although i don't know what his i don't
know about his commitment to it here in
the united states
really jake how about an apology for
that